some news outlets have claimed there's a
troubling pipeline from libertarianism
to the most revolting corners of the
alt-right movement their evidence is
that white supremacists Christopher
Cantwell the star of a vice documentary
about the racist tiki torch wielding
Charlottesville mob was once a figure in
the libertarian Free State Project and
the alt-right icon and white nationalist
Richard Spencer himself was once a Ron
Paul supporter and self-identified as a
libertarian anyone who claims to care
about individual liberty should reject
the overt racism in Charlottesville the
broadly defined alt right and the
watered-down alt light variants
represented by provocateurs like milo
gianopolous and YouTube personalities
stefan molyneux and laura southern as
well as the right-wing nationalism
pushed by recently fired White House
strategist Steve Bannon these
expressions of right-wing populism are
the antithesis of libertarianism and
they collapse under their own logic
and I think it's more accurate to say
that the override cares about Western
supremacy rather than white supremacy
Western civilization is our birthright
it makes all good things possible
undefended it collapses the fundamental
question of our time is whether the West
has the will to survive the alt-right
claims to be the savior of Western
civilization which apparently is on the
brink of collapse because Muslims and
Mexicans are invading our society they
come to countries they they rape women
they're having a very difficult time
learning not to rape women once you
replace one population with another it
will not be the same not even close
you know when you bring the third world
to the first world you don't get the
first world you get the third world
members of the alt-right point to the
sizable influx of immigrants to Europe
in the wake of destabilizing Middle
Eastern wars but America isn't Europe
which is one problem with this framing
of the West as some sort of monoliths
here's a straightforward look at
immigrants as a percentage of the u.s.
population sure there's an upswing since
around the end of the Vietnam War but
really it's a return to the historical
average and what was going on here in
the late 19th and early 20th centuries
as immigrants flooded in the Second
Industrial Revolution cars steal
electricity telecommunication and
America's rise as a global economic
superpower want to make America great
again
maybe free-flowing immigration combined
with an open marketplace is the winning
formula but let's get back to those
Western values
America's founders based their ideas on
Enlightenment values such as individual
property rights and free trade as
articulated by philosophers like John
Locke and Adam Smith and who did they
build their ideas in opposition to
mercantilist spre tection asur what we
today would call economic nationalists
post charlottesville Trump's recently
fired chief strategist Steve Bannon told
a reporter that white ethno nationalists
s-- are losers and clowns and then he
made a case for economic
nationalism economic nationalism we're a
nation with an economy not an economy
just in some global marketplace with
open borders we talk about free trade
it's not free trade it's stupid trade
China dumps everything that they have
over here no tax no nothing no problems
no no curfews no anything we can't get
into China President Trump is right that
free trade isn't always a two-way street
but his Nobel prize-winning economist
Milton Friedman explained any individual
country by itself on the average tends
to benefit from free trade regardless of
what the other countries do don't
believe him well recent polling finds
the majority of economists agree that
free trade has a net benefit an
empirical studies show a correlation
between fewer trade barriers and a
higher per capita GDP one study compared
countries that opened up trade and cut
tariffs to ones that didn't finding that
citizens in the freer trade countries
saw their incomes increase by an average
of 20% more than in closed economies
through international trade
middle-income consumers have seen their
purchasing power grow by as much as 30
percent and low-income consumers benefit
roughly twice as much trumps fans can
cheer when he pressures companies to
locate their manufacturing plants in
America but these success stories
unravel with closer scrutiny
just like the progressive left the all
trade wants to empower the federal
government just as long as the right
people are in power doling out benefits
to their favourite constituencies this
is why you'll hear all right leaders
speaking favorably of single-payer
health care when we enter this new stage
where we're talking about national
programs where we're talking about we
have a basic income program we have a
health care program
it's almost inherently racial it will
inherently you could say nationalize the
discourse or racialized the discourse
before he was ejected from the White
House Steve Bannon attempted to talk
Trump into boosting income taxes to fund
his nationalist agenda some right-wing
populists have even advocated using the
power of the state to force private tech
companies to be run like quasi
governmental public utilities since it
has the power to censor the Internet
Google should be regulated like the
public
utility it is to make sure it doesn't
further distort the free flow of
information the alt-right may be in for
the same sort of harsh lesson as the
left about what happens when you
opportunistically increase the power of
a government you're certain to lose hold
of one day so why does the philosophy so
it odds with its core values attract any
defectors from the libertarian movement
well what's most appealing are the
alt-right soppin to Foreign Wars its
nominal defense of free speech and a
valid sounding critique of P CX s after
all Milo yeah Annapolis made a name for
himself as a provocateur on campus
feminism is Kansa thank you very much
the truth is that the alt rights
commitment to free speech runs about an
inch deep many have engaged in similar
behaviors as the politically correct
progressives they decry forming online
mobs and boycotts to encourage private
entities to fire commentators like Kathy
Griffin and Raisa aztlán for political
speech deemed offensive and they've shut
down modernized stagings of
Shakespeare's Julius Caesar for the
offense of depicting the assassination
of a trump-like lead character they've
cheered a sitting presidents threats to
sue publications that criticized him and
his willingness to shut out journalists
whose coverage he doesn't like you can
fight for free speech and oppose
political correctness without
subscribing to this flawed ideology
libertarians have your back on that as
do many traditional conservatives and
some liberals like Jonathan Roush the
Brookings Institution scholar who
literally wrote the book on the topic in
1995 being offended is part of how we
learn
if you can't offend people then you
can't criticize people and if you can't
criticize people and ideas then there is
absolutely no way to figure out what
ideas are good and what ideas are bad
the alt rights America first nationalism
engenders of skepticism of foreign
military intervention that's sorely
lacking and washing
and that's what's most compelling about
the alt-right and the political
realignment it's forced with former
conservative Hawks like Ann Coulter
calling out Trump for troop surges in
the Middle East but even this anti
interventionism is soft ground because
if you delve into the mind of a figure
like Steve Bannon you'll uncover a
nightmare vision of a world already
engaged in global warfare we are in an
outright war against jihadists Islam
Islamic fascism and this war is is I
think metastasizing and the Albright's
focus on nationalism and racial and
ethnic identity doesn't bode well for a
more peaceful future the alt-right
ultimately amounts to a backwards
looking movement and that's what's most
concerning it's telling that their
beloved slogan make America great again
both harkens back to a mythical time
that never existed and was ripped off
from Ronald Reagan the alt-right is
about recapturing a non-existent passed
through vague but misleading appeals to
Western values libertarians are the true
defenders of the Enlightenment and
present a forward-looking vision that
centers on the power of individuals to
create their own experiences make their
own choices and foster a more peaceful
world if that's not for you
stick with the alt-right or its
spin-offs just know what you're signing
up for
[Music]
you